[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition
and today's episode is all about
tech in sports let's in fact title it
tech rules and who who do i have with me
my co-host
gary o'reilly gary hey hey neil oh god i
love having you gary and we love your
accent
straight from the uk and that's not why
we have you
it's because you're x pro uh footballer
soccer player i think they we call it
over here
uh so great to have you your perspective
and you you spent time as an announcer
so that was also good very very cool i
assume you were announcing
soccer yes not something else
they wouldn't let me loose on the royal
family
royal family need need full-time
announcers for what they
they're up to and chuck always good to
have you man oh it's good to be here
and your your body of knowledge of
sports always impresses me i don't want
to say surprises because that meant i
had low expectations
you meant surprise you just
you have a fluency that i i don't find
with many comedians i just want to thank
you
for lending that to this show oh yeah
sure
very excellent so um we you know we
could opine on this subject but
really what we really need is a an
expert
that's what start talk is all about
subject expert and we've got a professor
ray von fusche
rayvon welcome to star talk thanks so
much for having me
excellent you are professor in the
school of interdisciplinary studies in
purdue university that's the
boilermakers right it is
and you guys in indiana if i remember
correctly you don't have daylight
savings time there
is that still the case i think some
parts have daylight saving times but i
believe you know other parts don't so
we're we're splitting the difference
okay i don't think it's supposed to work
that way but
we're embracing the sherpa flexibility
of time
[Laughter]
so you are author of the
perfectly titled book for this episode
the game
changer yes techno-scientific revolution
in sports okay and also
black inventors in the age of
segregation
whoa oh we gotta bring you back for that
so you mean
up until last year
okay that's a good chunk here you're a
bit ahead of me i'm not sure
he's not even sure that's happened yet
yeah
[Laughter]
so you have a phd in science and
technology from cornell it's
great to have you on here so thanks for
for participating in our game changer
series which is sort of a
sub series within our our sports edition
so interdisciplinary studies that feels
kind of
sort of wishy-washy so where does the
science fit into that
wow man why you got to do that to my
mass i'm just asking
interdisciplinary we're going to do that
to his concentration you know
interpretationary uh i mean i'm just
gonna say that's uh that's very very uh
weak and women that is not what i said i
said i'm trying to understand it
asking questions okay all right so take
me there
what happens in interdisciplinary
studies you should be the biggest
champion of
interdisciplinary studies it's just
bringing together multiple different
disciplinary perspectives and asking
questions that are bigger and larger
than one disciplinary space
oh snap so it's like the cosmic
perspective for
science itself you know it's
oh thank you thank you okay that was
good but i wouldn't give it a a
an oh snap i mean that was i would save
the oh snap for
you know and there's the z-snap you know
you gotta
guys just wait there i'm gonna get the
snap-ometer
it's behind me here i'll bring it in and
we can wear it scenes it registers on
the scale
so so how far back would you say
technology
has impacted sports i can tell you i
used to row
and i was only told about this i never
read it
because i didn't want to believe it but
that there was a day when rowers
before they had the seat that rolled
okay the sliding seat they would grease
your butt
and you would slide back and forth on a
polished surface when you rode and i'm
thinking
damn but at that time would that have
been considered
high tech you know friction
low friction grease but sliding
increasing power to the stroke at what
point do we say
sports has been touched by technology my
perspective
is technology influences sport from the
beginning
so roughly 3 3000 bc
they have instances of wrestling
greco-roman wrestling
bodies and arms and the moment i would
say you potentially move
past that moment of people using their
bodies and arms you have
a ball a piece of equipment of any kind
it becomes technological
and all of a sudden that changes the
nature of sport
all of a sudden you go from using your
own body
to playing with something else that can
be manipulated by
an athlete a competitor
technology enters the game so it's a
tool it could be material science or
anything else
yes and okay so when they started
oiling themselves with olive oil
that was a technological advancement for
greco-roman wrestling
exactly because you know olive oil comes
in many different forms it could be
spanish italian
and depends on what part of the world
you're from you know maybe italian oil
is better than
spanish oil i don't know but all right
but when we move forward in time there's
certain sports that feel
distinctly backwards you know i think of
baseball
they're still using leather you have to
kill an animal for your leather glove
the ball is leather it's got rubber
bands on the inside
they spit they use pine tar
resin you know and i'm thinking was any
of that ever considered modern because
right now that stuff looks old yes
i think it's tremendously modern right
the the baseball bat has gone through
multiple evolutions in time from
very simple two by four
just get you two by four out so now you
go
to places like louisville and louisville
slugger the engineering of the bats is
very very serious and thoughtful about
the woods that are being chosen
how and where the wood is being
cultivated
uh it is deeply techno-scientific
as well as the ball right the ball is
going through has gone through multiple
iterations
even down to the more recent instances
of people talking about the baseball
being juiced
and a lot of some more recent research
has been studying the seams of the ball
and the question is you know how
the ball has changed and evolved over
time as part of this
continuous techno scientific evolution
you can't get the same leather that the
ball was made out of 100 years ago
because you killed the hulk we've killed
all those cows and
eventually but cows today are fatter so
maybe their lead their skin is thinner i
don't know
true and but tan is a kind of old-school
technology right early
late 19th early 20th century and
a lot of the materials are still being
tanned by the same
few factories in the united states
horween is one
factory that tans for the nba balls
and also nfl footballs so they're trying
to maintain the continuity but
i would say very deeply technological
inside it's
it's it's weird i want to i know chuck
and
and and gary have questions but uh it's
it's weird to think
that they want to be consistent with the
past
but for example they've now they've
changed the athletes diet
they've changed their exercise regimen
they've changed the medicine surrounding
it oh but the ball has to be exactly the
same
and this has to be exactly the same so
it's weird that the body is allowed to
change but
the other stuff related to the sport
isn't to me that
looks very inconsistent i i agree with
you completely it's totally inconsistent
the ball is not the same as it was 100
years ago
right that is not the same right right
in fact
the mound in a baseball field is six
inches lower than it used to be right i
mean they're changing stuff so
don't pretend like it's all pure right
so chuck what do you got
speaking of things changing is there a
technological advancement that can be
too much too soon too fast so that you
have
altered the game in such a way where
the spirit of the competition is
compromised
ooh that sounds like it like like you
rehearsed that question
no i just thought that it would sound
like
it's show all work yes compare and
contrast
no that popped into it that popped into
my head basically he's gonna use that
question on the next exam he administers
you know it
but no because you guys were just
talking about everything has changed
but you know those changes are kind of
gradual so can it happen in such a way
that
you know you look at it and you say no
that's too advanced that's
too much changed and you've you're
changing the spirit of the competition
itself
yes absolutely i mean there have been
multiple instances where the technology
has changed
the understanding of the sport one of
the biggest examples
in recent past is the speedo laser racer
swimsuit
which changed the
nature of the competition from
individual bodies
to the question about who is using which
existing suit who is using which new
technology
so you have world championships in say
2009 where
40 plus world records were broken in one
world championship
and it all has to do with the suit and
the technology well so it's no longer
about the athlete
no it's about the suit so the narrative
of the sport is like
traditionally part of what makes
baseball so unique is they say well it's
such a
simple sport it's just a ball in the bat
and it's about individual athletic
brilliance
and historically the same thing was
going would go for swimming it's just
athletic talent however
all of a sudden it transitioned from
which athlete how much time they spent
in the pool how much training they had
done
to who was wearing the fastest suit and
writes
sport governing bodies who are selling
athletic performance and not swimsuits
uh
had to change that so by 2010 they
banned all of these polyurethane
super high performance suits you know
that's
you know i i feel like old school like
i'm the grandpa on the porch
in the rocking chair when i say back in
my day you know
mark spitz had a hairy chest had a
mustache
and my boy still won all those gold
medals in the 1976 he actually swam in a
sweater
a sweater he was wearing a cardigan
while he was swimming
and still broke
in the snow yeah in fact it was ice he
swam in the ice
there are some very interesting
instances where the athletes actually
revolted
so most recently nba a handful of years
ago
introduced synthetic basketball to the
nba
and a handful of players primarily led
by steve nash and others
said that they had no part in changing
the ball
it was different it bounced different it
felt different
and eventually the nba players
association
was able to force the nba to go back to
its traditional leather ball
and the idea is that the spalding in the
nba was trying to produce a modern
techno-scientific ball
one that was grippier when it was wet
one that performed the better
it was more consistent right because if
you're thinking about leather on balls
they come from different animals
different cows the consistency is is
suspect
so you could create this new technology
that allowed you to have
really similar balls from game to game
to arena to arena to state to state
but the players said this ball was
different than they were used to playing
with
it changed the game in a substantive way
and they wanted the old leather ball
back so they should use they should use
free range cows for their leather balls
they're happy cows
um okay professor if i look back and i'm
using the word intentionally
i find one thing that seems to have
changed sport no matter which event it
is
more than anything else and it's cameras
i mean i'm am i the only person who
thinks um
cameras or has it had such a profound
effect on the way
we are engaged in sport now
well we that we the viewer or the viewer
the athlete
oh sure of course of course the viewer
but how is the athlete touched by a
camera
okay well some some had to be uh
using it because we have footage of
games
from way back before there was
television
somebody was filming that for some
reason for some reason i mean lombardi
was using
game footage to analyze opponents in the
mid 60s
and he would roll his defensive unit in
our offensive unity and sit them down
now watch this
now this is how this happens now without
sort of slow motion without instant
replay with that all of those clever
things that came through
for me this sport isn't as big football
does not take off without
massive tv audience and without the
upgrading cameras for me it doesn't
happen
so you're saying lombardi was just an
ordinary coach but he had really good
technology
the camera the the footage you putting
words in my notebook
i never said it i like it no he had an
asymmetric advantage if he's using
if if he's using video and or film and
other people aren't so
so what do you say here professor well
definitely i mean
two most recent examples uh i don't know
we're getting onto the world of cheating
but you know we think about the eastern
astros more
a little further back 2007 with the new
england patriots and spy gates
so there have been cameras used to
observe the opponent for
multiple different times and um for
different agendas and
lombardi is just one of many who have
used cameras to observe
the ways that people uh perform right
it's it's an old technique
uh it's espionage you think about
espionage that's what it is oh my gosh
71 blackbirds it's it's an old war
technique and sport is driven by
these metaphors of competition and
warfare
it's about gathering data using a camera
which will give people a very strong
visual representation of what's
happening so yeah
totally powerful i once visited the the
seattle
uh seahawks training camp and when they
were in there
they have a training dome basically like
one of them was inflatable things
and uh he wouldn't let me take pictures
in there they wouldn't want to just
show them their jobs he likes you he
doesn't love you
[Laughter]
yeah no that was i i not thought about
that until that moment where he says no
not in here
we're working on plays and you get to
see what the athletes are doing
so that's his polite way to
that's his strategic defense initiative
preventing
me from possibly um exploiting
his secrets so damn so so you so you're
you're going with that
with that war metaphor that's good well
i mean
a lot of coaches a lot of coaches see it
quite literally as
a war for x amount of minutes or hours
and
it's you know hopefully there's no debts
or casualties but to them it is
mano amano it is a war i i just look now
professor if i take my 200-inch tv
screen in the uh
in the ginormous man cave and i want to
watch
pictures that aren't very good quality i
need myself a 5k
picture therefore i got to have 5k
cameras and
all of a sudden i have such a sharp
image
am i opening up then the route for
artificial intelligence because
back in a blurry day artificial
intelligence couldn't analyze as
accurately or have i just made it it
didn't have the data you mean it
couldn't get the data
yeah you couldn't get the data couldn't
get the sharp enough image i mean i
think
for golf for for tennis for baseball
with spin rates
all those sort of different sports with
camera technology
comes an advance in other ways
technology
is enabled well wait wait it's just not
it's not only the 5k
it would be because you said spin rate
it's 5k plus a frame rate
right yes so that things aren't a blur
and then you can actually track
track this so so so rayvon where where
does that fit in
just high-res data time and spatial data
it is totally where much much
i think there's a lot of potential
within the context of sport because
now instead of having using say lombardi
taking photographs
you can have that data coming into your
home
and gary can now be the next um
sabermetrics data analyst and he's just
sitting on his couch slowing down the
frame rate
doing his analysis on his own so it
opens up in many ways it potentially
democratizes
the use of data in certain ways that was
not necessarily available because like
neil you said you couldn't take
photographs in the arena but
in many ways you might not need to be in
the arena anymore you can just sit at
home and
download the data and use it how you see
fit
all right we're going to take a quick
break we're going to shift from
cameras and the data it provides us so
that
we can gain an asymmetric advantage like
we've got to use these war terms let's
keep doing that if that's what this is
i'm going to see what more of high tech
has influenced the sport when star talk
continues
we're back star talks sports edition
we're talking about game changers and in
this case
what role tech has played in this and of
course we've got
professor rayvon foucher that's an e
with an accent
in case you didn't know how to pronounce
the trailing e uh he's at purdue
university who basically
literally figuratively and literally
wrote the book
on this and that book was titled the
game changer the techno scientific
revolution in sports when was that
published
uh rayvon 2017 2017 so it should still
be out there excellent who published it
johns hopkins university press good
she'll give them a shout out there okay
thanks for mentioning that
so with cameras of giving us sort of
uh some people who use it cleverly and
asymmetric
advantage if you connected the
information the cameras obtained
to computers and using that to
analyze so it's not just a human looking
at it we now
feed it to computers when would you at
what point did computers
start mattering in sports would you say
i would say
really when the computational power
started to push forward in a big way
late 90s early 2000s
and in many ways i think a big marker of
the combination of all these pieces is
2006 when we get the mit
sloan um conference on sports analytics
it's it's the one point where i think
that's the culmination of the moment
with
everyone seeing the power the
competition could have but i think
really it's early late 90s early 2000s
when
instead of having large-scale computers
the personal computer could do
a lot of the the data crunching and data
analytics you don't need to go to
your local university and asked for
super computer
time to do some data analytics and
that's when it became
a real powerful tool you know an
interesting uh
this is a little bit off the subject but
i'm going to slip it in there
because we were thinking warfare so
to design a fuselage of an airplane to
be
stealth requires very significant
calculations so that any surface that
reflects
a radio radar signal towards it
will not reflect it back towards the
detector at all
so that it doesn't show up and in the
1970s and 80s computing was so primitive
that they could only solve the equations
with straight lines
so the f-117 stealth fighter
has these surfaces flat surfaces
on it because that's the best they could
do this this they couldn't fit the
spline
the continual spline solution to the
shape of the fuselage
once the computing power boosted into
the 80s and into the 90s
then they could design the b2 stealth
bomber
and all the surfaces are curved on that
uh in all places
so that this is computing power having
it totally
affecting of course not only sports but
everything in our lives
yeah no i i think that connection is
deeply related because
arguably i think some of the people that
are doing that high level computing of
engineering are also interested in
sports does computing count
if you because i remember there was a
big deal in the in the u.s open
tennis open where ibm was brought in to
detect to see if the ball hit the line
or didn't and they re and it was like
wow this is
computing and it's this and i i remember
the enthusiasm behind that not everyone
was
embraced it but with with computers
as judges is this a thing as
referees with without a doubt and we are
here at this moment and this is a huge
controversy
because we're asking the big question of
do we want to eliminate humans
and their
well just say idiosyncrasies right or
or their biases you can't kick dirt on
the shoes of a computer
because you're angry with the call no
so major league baseball has
experimented already
with um in some of their minor leagues
strike zones with the strike zones
really
yeah yes and where you have
uh a home plate official who has
microphones in his headphones in his
ears and
the ball comes by and they call ball a
strike and
so now do you want your officials to be
bystanders or just reporting out
the information that's personal i want i
want a reporter
but i think wait wait why do you want a
reporter because
what do you need him for it's either is
a striker it isn't it's all part of the
game
no here's why you need them you need
them because there are things that
happen
at the plate that still require
sportsmanship
uh there's certain conduct that needs to
be uh monitored
there's also uh factors of cheating that
could happen
program that into the ai and get rid of
the empire
that's the whole point of ai it'll do
what the humans do but better
and this and this is computing power at
its next
extreme here correct yeah but
i think the limitations are that we as
the rules are written right now
they're not capable of enacting this
clear specificity that the ais can
right right because essentially the
the strike zone halfway between the
shoulder
and the waist that's that's the major
league baseball's
understanding of it but see that's that
i don't want him there
i don't want the ai for that even though
the ai from a camera angle might be able
to determine that
i only want it for inside outside over
the plate
that's all i want the ai for because
everything else
is still subjective there really isn't
a a there's not an objective strike zone
okay
you're in the wrong place here so you
just program into the ai
a subjectivity so it gets one in ten
calls wrong
how about that and you don't know which
call that's going to be no no no no now
we can now
in fact you could have the record you
could pre-load
the strike the ball strike record of any
ump you want
and they'll and it'll be them but here's
the problem with that
what okay what i don't want a computer
to be just as stupid as me
okay gary you're gonna ask ask him about
moneyball and stuff like what what
oh no well okay moneyball was was
pre-computer power
um that was all done with a sort of
human brain i think but it's still
analytics
it's still analytics i mean it is the
birth of analytics in sport to
to another level but it's still
pre-computers now what we've just
discussed here
has got me jumping even further forward
professor am i wrong here
where normally the rules of the game the
rules of the sport the laws that are
engaged to play
or execute the performance are written
by humans
with the technology that we've just
discussed with chuck and neal and
yourself
are we not at the point where the
technology is in advance of the rules
and the rules have now got to play
catcher are we in that zone already or
is that something in the next few years
we're we're in that zone and i think
people are not very happy that we're in
that zone
for instance what is a catch in the nfl
right and
it's possession right control
it's control well it's possession and
control and a football move
and so the question is right you know
i'm on board with you neil you can
clearly program an ai
to make that decision but the problem is
we haven't made that decision outside of
the
of the ai to even have that discussion
right
so if we can say what to do if you can't
if you don't even know what it is you're
saying it's doing exactly so but i like
the idea that technology is pushing us
to make those
have to make those decisions because now
you know we live in a world where the ai
can do it and the only reason
we don't have a clear understanding of
what a catch is because we're not
willing to make that decision we're not
being willing to
lay that that terminology down in text
and say
we're doing this because the technology
exists at this moment to make
clear accurate definitive decisions
somebody's got to judge
whether the the person was in control of
the ball
to judge it to be a correct catch and we
and that's not written down anywhere
it's just somebody's looking at it
they know that they see it yes exactly
it's like that was control that wasn't
control
or you know he was bobbling some some
will say that the ball
moving at all is a lack of control
whereas others will say
it was moving while he had it trapped to
his body
therefore he still had control yeah but
did his knee hit the ground before that
happened
right right exactly okay i got another
one for you this i think about this all
the time the first i've ever gone public
on this
uh so what you can do is you have a
picture
and you can get the statistics
of of how of the spread
of where the ball is thrown to the
catcher
okay and so you can look at the
statistical likelihood
that that picture is going to throw
outside of that zone
okay so if one of the pitches comes
and floats up and damn near hits the
batter in the head you eject the pitcher
if that's a two
or three sigma throw whereas if the
picture's just wild today
then the throw that kind of goes near
the head
there's no no intent there because the
pitcher's control has not demonstrated
that that could be con intentional
so you can statistically judge whether
the throw
was at the person's head or not yeah but
isn't tim music a part of the game
okay okay the fact is you just have to
know whether the pitcher and the hitter
have got something going on historically
right
and he's likely to ding one off his
helmet and it's all going to break loose
and the bench is clear
all right how about this let me let me
move this forward my father used to run
track
and he uh at the finish line
there would be people with stop watches
and each person it was their job
you would time the second place person
the third or the fourth
whichever okay and then they come and
compare all the stopwatches
all right this involves human reaction
time all of this that's all went to
cameras
it's now digital and in swimming they do
it to a hundredth of a second
um is there going to be a day where
we're not really improving all that much
so we got to go down to like to ten
thousandth
of a second or a hundred thousandths of
a second you could set a world record by
being
a hundred thousandths of a second faster
than the previous record
yeah absolutely i mean we're already
here because we can time
well below the the chosen level and yes
hand timing has been problematic um and
they've been slowly this is in swimming
and swimming yeah yeah
across the sport right so you know in
the 1950s they're saying hand timing was
off by a quarter a second by the 60s
they're saying roughly hand timing was
off by about a tenth of second
so people were getting better but now
timing is all fully automated
and right we're at the point right now
where
we can time even more detailed than
not so for instance in the last handful
of years there's been a couple ties and
world cups skiing however they're
timing down to i think the millionth of
a second in world cup skiing
so yeah but they're not i bet they're
not tied to a millionth of a second
so they could have easily picked the
winner there exactly
but but they don't want to because i
think there the argument is that
we we don't believe that that the
infrastructure sport is clear enough to
time to that level
um and you gave it the instance of
swimming
it's impossible to build a completely
perfectly square swimming pool right
it's a pouring a big massive concrete
block okay your hair
i mean my house isn't straight how can
you think about pouring this liquid
substance and making it perfectly
straight so in theory what
one lane is longer than another and if
we're starting to time down
to the millionth the 10 millionth of a
second it may be
that the pool is not square instead of
someone swam back
or you didn't arrive at your destination
with the correct phasing of your stroke
and you had to like bring your hair on
another on another swing and then you
just lost a
quarter of a second right there okay so
you can't it doesn't okay so this
happens in science all the time
where it's possible to have excess
precision
for the question that has been posed
and using that precision becomes
completely misleading and in fact
false yes cool wow
that's what we get so we mean
that's a very sad state it's like don't
forget i'll give you an example i'll
give an example so in track and field
i think they still do this it's not it
when your head crosses
the front line it's your chest okay
which is is that why everybody
leans that's why they lean right they
okay it's your chest
well if you can measure this to a
millionth of a second that's the time
between your shirts crossing the line
and your flesh
okay but they're only measuring your
shirt so maybe people will
wear like big bosoms or something
i mean tell me i didn't have these
blasted man
boobs no no no i'm just agreeing
with raymond here that you end up
measuring things that are not even
what you're trying to measure and part
of it is we don't have the rules to
to deal with that kind of accuracy
that's it so in the accuracy that we do
have and that we're using right now
are there events and i know if they are
they would be
very infrequent but in world-class
events do we ever have ties anymore do
we ever have somebody
coming in on the clock at the same exact
time
the answer is yes but we can time it
better and show that they're not at the
same time but then you're measuring
other things
at that point that this is the point i
was trying to make
we have to have a way i'm saying it has
has there been instances where we've had
ties
i mean yes yes in in 100 meter dash
and when you have a tie two people stand
on the on the podium
at the number one spot they omit the
second spot and then a person comes in
third
so there's no silver medal given when
that happened okay that's how they
that's how they do that i was just
unaware if they had never happened
but that shouldn't happen any longer it
wouldn't have to happen but
let's take a quick break and we'll come
back we'll just digest all of this and
shoot the [ __ ]
with ravon our professor at large
helping us unpack technology and sports
when we return
we're back star talk sports edition
i got professor fouche from purdue
university the boilermakers
and that's a whole town full of
engineers right there
so you've got just the expertise we need
for this show
we're talking about game changers or
athletes and but in this case we're
talking about technology and
so we've got in recent past some
examples of
uh damn near geriatric highly performing
athletes
[Laughter]
name names night names
so uh what do we have we have uh how old
is lebron lebron lebron is like 36
yeah okay that's a foot in the grave
right there and tom brady
was it was 43 in the super bowl died
three years ago and didn't even know it
so but they're at their height they're
not just put out to pasture and we keep
them just because they're
they sell tickets they're actually
performing at the top of their creations
another one yeah so tell me about
technology and
health and surgery and
and and all the rest of that there'd be
medical technology of course
i think clearly we're at the front edge
of
what we can do physiologically with
with athletes amount of at least put a
football players right
and we you mentioned two examples lebron
lebron is on pace
to have the most mileage on his legs of
any nba player in history of the game
uh similarly tom brady playing
at his level until 43. just remind me
lebron came right out of high school
right yeah
correct right right okay okay and
so obviously there's a whole
infrastructure that's allowing these
athletes to perform
longer and at the highest level and
it's not just a crisp ball of wheaties
every morning
that's allowing them to perform at that
high level
right there's a whole infrastructure of
health professionals
bodily treatments scientific and
technological training methods that
allow
these athletes to continue to play diet
diet is in there too yeah all of this
and so all right so let's let's unpack
the
900 pound elephant in the room uh if
technology helps you win if you have the
technology and other people don't what's
the difference between that and cheating
um it's all about perspective right of
all kinds of things
so from my perspective
sport is not about equality
sport is about maintaining a competitive
advantage for as long
as possible legally or legally
so i think there's a great space when we
have the conversation about cheating
uh and i would say it's not it's only
cheating until it's been officially
banned
within a sporting governing body
or sporting environment so fosberry
didn't cheat
when he jumped backwards over the bar
with the fosberry flop he did not
he was not cheating was just smarter
neil i mean let's
because i had knee ligament
reconstruction
right now the whole idea of that is it
is stronger
after surgery than before i damaged oh
but am i is am i now doped have i now
body doped
by having surgery that's actually made
my knee ligament
stronger i mean this is like the tommy
john surgery
in baseball correct so this is the point
the professor is making i think
until it's made illegal it's okay but is
it
is it in the spirit of things
cheating i would say it's completely
within the spirit of sport right because
the spirit of sport is about winning and
i think that's what makes the technology
and science so powerful and so awesome
at the moment
no in elementary school it's about
participating okay just to make
thank you just let's get that straight i
think we're all past elementary school
so you get your participation trophy
speak for yourself oh chuck i like that
your participation trophy on your shelf
there chuck exactly
yeah oh so i mean technology
is the the place where you can gain
and acquire the biggest competitive
advantage and
so many of the the technologies
computational processes
health mechanisms the governing bodies
of the sport aren't looking at
and aren't thinking about so therefore
it's kind of an open world for people to
experiment
and see what the limits are and how they
can improve
their bodies wait gary is that a real
thing from my notes here
like ghost pacers from an augmented
reality glasses you wear is that real
uh by the way sir yes damn
i know so we this thing is now
otherworldly so imagine imagine i gave
you a pair
of look like a normal pair of sunglasses
you pop them on you're going to go run
around the track
then all of a sudden this augmented
reality
appears in front of you and you can't
catch it
because it's been set at a certain pace
imagine you're an elite athlete we
talked about it in a recent show right
about the marathon breaking two hours
right kip koji imagine he was training
with one of these
that just made him run faster and faster
and faster until he gets himself
under two hours this is the sort of
technological advancement we're finding
ourselves with
outside of someone's got to run in front
of you burn themselves out and then
someone else has got to come in so you
go through half a dozen pacemakers
during a marathon
right this thing's going to run running
but that really isn't very different
from
the way anyone trains now i mean that's
the same as a sparring partner
the better your sparring partner the
better boxer you will be
wait if a sparring partner kick your ass
every day then
you should be the sorry partner that's i
was going to say or
you're just not going to be boxing you
know
um but but you don't want to spar with
somebody who can't box very well
because that doesn't help you at all so
you know
the pacing i think pacing is different
uh plus i would i wouldn't want i
wouldn't want to not be able to catch
the the augmented reality like you set
it up so i catch it right at the finish
line
and then i have some sense of triumph so
okay
i was about to say there is how about
what's the old
the uh experiment where they took uh
a mice or a rat and they put it and they
let it swim halfway and then they
they wouldn't they wouldn't allow it to
ever reach the the edge
and so it ended up giving up and
drowning
i mean can you break somebody's spirit
by training them
to a place where they never receive a
reward
you probably can chuck but i think it's
the whole
now the technology has to be managed
because otherwise it as you've just
described
is a destructive right so rayvon what my
co-hosts are telling us here is that
athletes
they need a little a little um
tasty tidbit every time they achieve
something yeah like they feed the
dolphin in the swimming pool
so you can't keep the carrot out there
forever you gotta you gotta
toss them a fish toss them a fish when
they when they get it right
but but where is this headed where are
we going 10 years from now what's going
on
i mean i think this is getting back to
what chuck was saying about and and just
pushing the limits right so
the outer edge is this whole world of
neural stimulation
right so yeah right right the idea
is that athletes
the brain is the limiting factor within
athletic ability and competition
so in a sense your brain breaks down
i was going to tweet that about a week
ago i was saving for a good moment
it's that very thing right the uh elite
athletes are limited not by their bodies
but by their brains by their minds
right so some people have been saying
research is saying that well
what's happening is you're getting
central fatigue in that all of a sudden
you're getting weaker signals from your
body
from your brain to your muscles so
therefore
you work on a series of neural
stimulations create
more plasticity within the brain and
allow
and train yourself to push
farther and deeper into the pain zone
and
allow your body to um produce stronger
signals to your muscles so you'll be
ignoring
your evolutionary signs to stop
yes you're you're you're or or even
overriding them
overwriting that's a better that's a
better term
and so the idea is to to okay but we're
all gonna be like the dude who ran
from marathon to athens and to report on
the battle and then just drop dead
that's what's going to happen if you
don't drop dead at the finish line then
you didn't give all the energy you could
have is that what you're telling us
that's that's where the goal is right
the kellen winslow it's the kellen
winslow effect
like if they don't carry you off the
field then you didn't do your job
don't leave anything on the phone i mean
we've had this
this thought process in in sport and in
training for
for decades and decades you train harder
than you compete
so as when you compete you're not at the
edge of your envelope
and chuck and i had a discussion
somewhere wait wait wait wait i can tell
you what
that makes sense to hear it but it's not
true
because no one breaks world records
while they're training i know but once
you get into the element of competition
other stuff kicks in and you push push
push so you've all
you know what you need to do to win
and so you train beyond that so if
anything ever comes along you're always
working within comfort and without the
stress so you've got that wriggle room
to push further onwards
to get to be even better but i'm not
convinced people on breaking world
records and
and training they're just not organized
and have the the record keeping i think
people are
going extremely fast and powerful in
training they're just not
officially sanctioned right we think
about official sanctioning events the
absence of data on that yes
okay nothing would piss me off
then more than to break a world record
while i was practicing while nobody was
looking nobody was there
well that won't happen now chuck because
everything is filmed
absolutely everything is filled and we
go back to the cameras where the super
high
speed cameras with tens of thousand
frames a second and there's nothing goes
past
anybody anymore so it will be captured i
mean look at
our our dear friend sasha cohen she
produced
uh was it a quadruple sao count
acquired yes in a warm-up routine rather
than competition and she landed it
it's on film so therefore she owns one
right so
credit to her so let me ask you this
then speaking of that because she never
did it in competition
not to not to disparage her in any way
but did the fact is she didn't
is there is there any technology
that can monitor
and help an athlete kind of stay
in the zone so that
when the time comes they're just popping
in the zone
right when they need to be um yeah so so
i think this is one of the leading edges
of where we are as well there are
companies that are in the process of
trying to track biometric data
and figure out peak performance so
generally a lot of these organizations
and companies and
research labs have have gotten very very
good
at trekking a series of biometric data
points and being able to determine
if you'll be at your highest level of
peak performance
so that's the part they're really good
at however
the part where it breaks down is the
less biometrically dated
data related events so you could be
ready to perform
at your highest level but you got an
argument with your mother
your girlfriend broke up with you you
got in the car accident
all of these other social things that
interven
intervene in one's life may derail you
no no raven you just put in brain
implants
that will that'll rub that out i mean
let's go 10 years into the future so
it's just your brain so therefore we're
just
so they won't just go robotic all the
way to the bodies
because they're just the bodies you have
your match and you go home
you're like who are you raymond i wish i
had a rebuttal to that sentence and i
don't
yeah you're right if once you start
tickling and twitching
brain cells interrupting or enhancing
neurochemical synapses uh you're
you're a machine at that point all right
so now let me ask you this speaking of
machines is there or will there be
an acceptable time for implantation
to be a part of any sport implantation
of what
oh of of anything whether it's um not
just sensors but
augmentation so the implantation
actually heightens your performance
okay so wait wait suppose you're talking
prosthetics
because i have a bad heart and i get a
and i get a pacemaker
okay and now i'm now i'm a senior
running in a
you know 65 and older race did the
pacemaker prevent me from dying
yes did it make me win the race i don't
know but there's a lot of stuff we can
put in our bodies and
already is put in our bodies so rayvon
where where does that sit going forward
i think we're already at the point where
generally i think people are going to
get more comfortable with it
because i think we're understanding as a
society that
the world in which we live is techno
scientifically driven
and mediates all things that we live
with and
we're getting to the point where we're
going to have to give up on this
this illusion that sport is all about
the human body
and just generic performance
the technology is here you know we can
talk about the pacemaker we can talk
about all these kind of technological
innovations
and eventually it's going to come to the
point where
we're going to be more interested in the
great athletic performances and what the
technology can bring
than i think old school representations
or ideas of
what an athlete should be you know
athletes go through surgical procedures
right
you know kevin durant yeah he's back
playing
and that's pretty amazing but what
happened with him remind me
this is kevin durant the basketball
player yeah yeah
so multiple injuries he's gone through a
series of injuries um
um some some gruesome ankle feet
calf injuries and i think i don't even
know the extent of the bodily injuries
but
an injury enough that allowed him he had
to sit out a whole season
right and so choose him or any other
athletes who are sitting at long periods
of time
and they're getting back
because there's a massive amount of
techno-scientific research to allow
their
themselves to retrain
their bodies that's not why they're
getting bad they give me because they
make them it's money
that's why i'm not retiring your ass you
get back on that court i'm going to
pay that for that contract true but i
mean the only way they get back is
there's
there's got to be something to make it
happen yeah of scientific and
technological
innovation going on going forward and so
i think we're getting to the point where
if athletes are going to get injured are
we willing to say well
maybe we should implant certain things
re-configure their bodies because we
would like to see tom brady play another
decade
wow and if some of us would yeah yeah
some of us well no i the only way i'd
like to see him play another day
is if he were wearing an eagles uniform
other than that
so i mean professor are we are you
actually saying that we're going to see
some crusty old 40-somethings performing
at the very top
of major league baseball nfl nba well
baseball may be still but um are we
going to see more dynamic sports
populated by older athletes i think so
okay i have to modify that i think where
pure skill matters
yes but where physicality no
no right yeah so so brady
is not the wide receiver at 43.
no okay so that's the difference right
here
yeah and and his and his offensive line
becomes
way more important than it ever has yeah
exactly because if anybody gets through
that's the end of tom brady
right it's exactly yeah you don't want
to say that
so guys we got to bring this to a close
raven it sounds like you're
you're all in on this technology thing i
don't want to put words in your mouth
but it sounded like
you're you're ready to take this
wherever it can go
i wouldn't say i'm ready to take away
wherever you go but i think
we're society are getting to the point
where
we are interested in seeing what
technology can bring
to the human body and athletic
performance and
i think the next steps are really right
around the corner
in our lifetimes you're saying yes
definitely in our lifetime okay
all right dude well this has been
fascinating and
i'm sure we only just began to plumb the
depths of this topic
all right guys uh we got to call it
there so uh thank you uh
uh professor for joining us for this and
uh guys gary chuck always good to have
you
thank you co-host this has been star
talk sports edition
game changers i'm neil degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist
occasionally posing as an ex-athlete
for these shows i hope to see you next
time
as always